- [Allen-Sanchez] You need to find out which angle
shows the largest increase in temperature.
You need to design an
experiment that shows that.
It's a design challenge.
- I mean, it's going up.
The temperature's going up.
- [Student] Oh, my god, really?
- [Student] What temperature is it at?
- [Holthuis] At the Stanford Center of
Assessment, Learning, and Equity
we produce some curriculum
that was aligned
to the new standards
that had just come out
at that point.
The curriculum really engages students,
and I think that some of that comes from
having interesting projects
that they're working on
and providing the options, the choice,
the decision making.
And really turning over
some agency to them.
This really is a whole
different way of thinking
about science education.
- [Ryan] What we were committed to was adopting
and using a curriculum
that would break the
cycle of predictability
of who would succeed in science courses
based upon their gender and ethnicity.
- [Holthuis] Performance assessment is one
that engages students, is really rich,
and measures much more
than just what do you know,
what facts can you tell me or regurgitate.
- You're designing an angle
of incoming light experiment.
- They're really often projects.
They ask students to bring in skills,
they ask them to bring in their content,
to make connections,
and to pool all that together
into a larger product.
- [Allen-Sanchez] The assessment itself is
really taking the information
that they've learned and applying it.
So, as opposed to giving them a page
and saying fill in this blank,
circle this letter,
give me this definition.
- It's going up really fast.
- It's at about 79.
- [Student] It's at 90 degrees.
- 'Cause really any kid can memorize
any of that information,
but can they apply it
to an actual real-world application?
- [Ryan] We recognize that
students walk in the door
of this classroom with
issues of status behind them.
That they recognize themselves
as being a science person
or a non-science person.
- So, this would be a 90 angle
or a right angle,
and then when it goes out...
- And that it's through
student discourse and group work
that they will start
to dispel those beliefs
about not only themselves
but about their peers.
- [Holthuis] So that's where we developed,
and why we developed,
an entire unit for teachers to implement
at the start of the year
where they help students think
about what kind of behaviors
are expected of you
when you're working in small groups.
- It has to be a direct
angle to the experiment.
- Direct angle? Or are
their any other angles?
- Well, you could do
any other angle, but...
- The group roles really
help kids understand
that they have a task and
they really can't just be idle
and by themselves and hide in a corner.
- So, my job is the recorder/reporter.
So, with that job, I have to write down
all our notes and all our
step-by-step stuff like this.
- Right, they have to actually participate
in order to achieve whatever it is
that they're trying to achieve.
- [Ryan] Ongoing professional development
is coming from the communities of teachers
at science collaborating,
making decisions about their own practice,
and then also giving us feedback.
- The roadblock I find
with some of the students
who finish really quickly,
is that they're doing it because
they want to do that piece,
they want to do an extra piece
that they're interested in.
- [Holthuis] To have somebody who has been involved
in the development of the curriculum,
that same person takes it back
to their own classroom and tries it out,
you get really deep insight.
It makes for much more robust curriculum,
because you're getting away
from content, content, content
and saying, okay, do you know the content,
and can you do something with it?
- [Allen-Sanchez] I think it's
been really fruitful.
The students seem to have a
much more focused perspective
on what we're supposed to do.
I have a much more focused perspective
- [Holthuis] It has really
supported student learning tremendously.